the US might be kind of getting
sanctioned by Europe this is not the
language that's being used to report
this but it's sort of what's going on
the European Union has announced that
going forward it's only going to make
trade deals with countries that have
signed on to the Paris climate agreement
period and of course we've talked about
the backstory of Donald Trump's mere
presence in the Oval Office hurting our
reputation we've talked about the
embarrassment of the United States as a
result of Trump taking steps like saying
the u.s. is out of the Paris climate
agreement saying things like climate
change is a hoax created by the Chinese
that has led directly that the United
States being kept out of conversations
about climate and increasingly we're not
really seen as a serious leader on a
number of issues including climate now
if Trump does indeed withdraw from the
Paris climate agreement there would be
no more trade deals with European
countries and that's not good for the
United States remember that even though
Trump has frequently and loudly
announced that he's pulling away from
the Paris climate deal the would the
transaction wouldn't actually happen
until 2020 so conceivably Trump could
actually reverse that decision but if
Trump follows through there are going to
be serious consequences TTIP is one it's
an agreement that's being negotiated
between the EU and the US and whether or
not we think it's a good agreement if
the United States is kept out as an even
even as a negotiating party because
we're out of the Paris climate agreement
that's bad for the United States and
remember the u.s. is the only country
that has opted out of the Paris climate
agreement at first Syria and Nicaragua
had also opted out Syria was just tied
up in a civil war but eventually opted
in Nicaragua initially opted out because
they felt that the deal just wasn't
strong enough they've since signed on
meaning the u.s. is the only country not
to have signed on so far there are
however other countries that haven't yet
ratified the agreement and those include
interestingly turkey with their
dictatorial president air dawuan
and Russia that's a coincidence some
kind right people need to wake up okay
there are consequences to the Trump
presidency and this is a sanction by
another name now I know it's not
actually a sanction on the United States
but the US has decided we're out of the
Paris climate agreement and now you have
a whole host of countries saying well
then we're not going to do trade deals
with you and the impact of it even
though it is not a sanction by name the
impact is very similar to the United
States being sanctioned this is a huge
embarrassment yeah and of course Trump
promised to renegotiate our trade deals
you like the best trade deals it's hard
to do that when these European leaders
won't even sit at the table with yeah it
seems that the trade deals are going to
be renegotiated but the United States is
not going to be part of those
negotiations good thing though right we
don't need those commie Europeans
telling us what to do I mean that's the
view that will be the view from some
committed trumpets you just say hey this
is actually fantastic and and in the
interest of being fully thorough we
don't know that the EU will follow
through with this right they've said
that it's what they're going to do until
they do it we don't know that they will
could just be some strong arming to get
some leverage maybe would be and of
course strong-arming is the strong armor
is not something again that makes Trump
look like a particularly good negotiator
or particularly strong which is sort of
par for the course it's what we've been
learning since he became president of
the United States discuss this with us
on our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash re d di t stay with us we've got
part two of my interview with the
Martians Andy we're next if you gave me
the task of picking out a wine that I
was going to love but it couldn't be a
wine I had tried before I'd be in
trouble
needless to say I wouldn't know where to
start and that's where wink comes in
spelled WI NC wink makes it easy for you
to discover great wines by shipping new
wines matched to your tastes and
personalized to you these are wines
you're really going to like and they're
shipped right to your door all you do is
open and enjoy them and unlike the
grocery store where you're not going to
get help selecting wines
you're not going to get delivery to your
door with wink you get to explore rare
and interesting wines from around the
world tailored to you from the comfort
of your home go to try wink calm /
Pakman that's t ry wi and c.com / pakman
fill out the palate profile quiz they
ask you very simple questions that will
help the system figure out what wines
you might like and then as you get wines
try wines and review the wines the
system will get even better at
suggesting wines that you will like no
membership fees cancel anytime skip any
month 100% satisfaction guarantee and
for a limited time get $20 off when you
go to try wink comm / Pakman that's t ry
wi and see comm / Pakman for $20 off try
wink calm forward / Pakman